we do have some breaking news though for  you on target a management shakeup their  Olivia Sterns is breaking it down from  the newsroom Olivia hey there Alex will  target has come out this morning saying  that their CEO and chairman Gregg  Steinhafel who's been with target since  1987 is now stepping down it is  effective immediately in his place the  CFO John Mulligan will be stepping up he  will become the new CEO he will also  become the president of Roxanne Austin a  current member of target's board  she will step in as non-executive  chairman they're also asking Gregg  Steinhafel to stay on with target to  serve as an advisor in this period of  change they say now is the right time  for leadership change at target again  these changes are effective immediately  Gregg Steinhafel stephene stepping down  at as CEO and president chairman of the  board of target in his place  CFO John Mulligan effective immediately  Alex